[Music]
foreign
[Music]
intervention
[Music]
[Applause]
historically low gas prices a boy band
for every block and Philips CDI and pogs
I mean maybe we just had it too good
during the 90s because audiences weren't
flocking much to horror movies this
decade
[Music]
the first half of this decade was
notoriously rough for the horror genre
as diminishing production value lost
craft and sequel blow buried the genre
Jason Michael and Freddie all got
canceled with only Wes Craven's New
Nightmare getting good enough reviews to
show up on this list even more new
nightmares is post-modern metastory
would pave the way for Craven's own
scream which would revive War leading
into the 21st century
what do you want
then why don't you show your face you
[ __ ] coward
my pleasure
other highlights from this era in horror
movies include the only one to ever win
best picture the rise of Peter Jackson
and Guillermo del Toro sophisticated
adult fair and winking B-movie mashups
for this list we've included titles with
at least 10 reviews and according to
their score and average review are
ranked by adjusted Tomato Meter like a
kiss from a rose or a rotting vegetable
we're counting down the best 1990s
horror movies
foreign
[Music]
starting with number 10 scream 2.
Sydney and tabloid reporter Gail weather
survived the events of the first scream
but their nightmare isn't over when two
college students are murdered at a sneak
preview of stab a movie based on the
events from the first film it's clear
that a copycat killer is on the loose
Sydney and Gail as well as fellow
survivors Deputy Dewey and Randy have to
find out who is behind the new murder
spree before they all end up dead
starring David Arquette Nev Campbell
Courtney Cox and directed by Wes Craven
critics say as with the first film
Scream 2 is a gleeful takedown of scary
movie conventions that manages to poke
fun at terrible horror sequels without
falling victim to the same fate
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
number nine The Blair Witch Project
found video footage tells the tale of
three film students who have traveled to
a small town to collect documentary
footage about the Blair Witch a
legendary local murderer now over the
course of several days the students
interview townspeople and gather Clues
to support the tale's veracity but the
project takes a frightening turn when
the students lose their way in the woods
and begin hearing horrific noises
starring Heather Donahue Michael C
Williams Joshua Leonard and directed by
Daniel Myrick and Eduardo Sanchez
critics say full of creepy campfire
scares mock DOC The Blair Witch Project
keeps audiences in the dark about its
titular villain proving once more that
imagination can be as scary as anything
on screen
[Music]
please help us
this is not the way to get out of here
I think it's safe to say at this point
that we're lost
I don't know what to do
all right let's not light a fire tonight
yeah it's because two nights in a row we
didn't light one the first night and
nothing happened nothing happened we
light fires they know that I haven't
heard anything follow us we should even
turn that light off too
number eight Tremors repair man Val
McKee and Earl Bassett are tired of
their dull lives in the small desert
town of perfection Nev but just as the
two try to skip town they happen upon a
series of mysterious deaths and a
concerned seismologist studying
unnatural readings below the ground now
with the help of an eccentric couple the
group fights for survival against giant
worm-like monsters hungry for human
flesh starring Kevin Bacon Fred Ward
Finn Carter and directed by Ron
Underwood critics say an affectionate
throwback to 1950s creature features
Tremors reinvigorates its genre tropes
with a finely balanced combination of
horror and humor
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
broke into the wrong rec room ninja you
back
number seven Dead Alive
overprotective mother veracost Grove
spying on her grown Sun Lionel as he
visits the zoo with the lovely Paquita
is accidentally bitten by The Fearsome
Sumatran rat monkey when the bike turns
his beloved mother into a zombie and
Lionel tries to keep her locked safely
in the basement but her repeated escapes
turn most of the neighbors into The
Walking Dead who then crash a high
society party thrown by Lionel's boorish
Uncle Les starring Timothy Baum Diana
penielver Elizabeth Moody and directed
by Peter Jackson critics say the
delightfully Gonzo tale of a Love Struck
teen and his zombified mother Dead Alive
is extremely gory and exceedingly good
fun thanks to Peter Jackson's affection
for the tastelessly sublime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for breakfast
number six Chronos
antique dealer Jesus Chris stumbles
across Kronos a 400 year old Scarab that
when it latches onto him grants him
Youth and eternal life but also athers
for blood as Jesus enjoys his Newfound
Vitality he's unaware that a dying old
man Dieter de LaGuardia has sent his
nephew on hell to find the Scarab and
bring it back to him but Jesus will not
give immortality up easily even risking
the life of his orphan granddaughter
starring Federico Lupe Ron Perlman
Claudia Brooke and directed by Guillermo
del Toro critics say Guillermo del
Toro's unique feature debut Chronos is
not only gory and stylish but also
charming and intelligent
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get ready for some more
[Music]
[Music]
number five misery
after a serious car crash novelist Paul
Sheldon is rescued by former nurse Annie
Wilkes who claims to be his biggest fan
Annie brings him to her remote cabin to
recover where her obsession takes a dark
turn which she discovers that Sheldon is
killing off her favorite characters from
his novels as Sheldon devises plans for
escape and he grows increasingly
controlling even violent as she forces
the author to shape his writing to sue
her Twisted fantasies starring James
Khan Kathy Bates Francis sternhagen and
directed by Rob Reiner critics say
elevated by standout performances from
James Khan and Kathy Bates misery is one
of the best Stephen King adaptations to
date she she died she just slipped away
Slipped Away
slipped away she didn't just slip away
you did it
yo daddy
[Music]
I thought you were good Paul
but you're not good you're just another
lying old dirty birdie
and I don't think I better be around you
for a while
foreign
don't even think about anybody coming
for you
not the doctors that's your agent not
your family
because I never called them
nobody knows you're here
and you better hope nothing happens to
me
because if I die
you die
number four arachnophobia
after a nature photographer dies on
assignment in Venezuela a poisonous
spider hitches a ride in his coffin to
his hometown in rural California where
arachnophobe Dr Ross Jennings has just
moved in with his wife Molly and young
son how convenient as Town residents
start turning up dead Jennings begins to
suspect spiders and must face his fears
is he and no-nonsense exterminator
Delbert McClintock fight to stop a
deadly infestation starring Jeff Daniels
Harley Jane Kozak John Goodman and
directed by Frank Marshall critics say
Arachnophobia may not deliver genuine
chills but it's an affectionate solidly
built tribute to Hollywood's classic
creature features
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
don't mention it
number three ring
when her niece is found dead along with
three friends after viewing a supposedly
cursed videotape reporter Rico asakawa
sets out to investigate along with her
ex-husband ryuji Rico finds the tape
watches it and promptly receives a phone
call informing her that she'll die in a
week determined to get to the bottom of
the curse Rico and ryuji discovered the
video's origin and attempt to solve an
old murder that could break the spell
starring nanako matsushima hiroyuki
Sonata Miki nakatani and directed by
hideo Nakata critics say ring combines
Supernatural elements with anxieties
about modern technology in a truly
frightening and unnerving way
what's up
[Music]
what up
[Music]
[Music]
number two The Sixth Sense
young Cole Sierra is haunted by a dark
secret he's visited by ghosts Cole is
frightened by visitations from those
with unresolved problems who appear from
the Shadows he's too afraid to tell
anyone about his anguish except child
psychologist Dr Malcolm Crowe as Dr Crow
tries to uncover the truth about Cole's
supernatural abilities the consequences
for client and therapists are a jolt
that awakens them both to something
unexplainable starring Bruce Willis
Haley Joel Osment Tony Collette and
directed by M Night Shyamalan critics
say M Night shyamalan's the Sixth Sense
is a twisty ghost story with all the
style of a classical Hollywood picture
but all the chills of a modern horror
flick
foreign
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Sleepy Hollow
set in 1799 Sleepy Hollow is based on
Washington Irving's classic tale The
Legend of Sleepy Hollow faithful to the
dreamy custom-bound world that Irving
Paints in his story the film mixes
horror fantasy and romance and features
an extraordinary cast of characters that
dabble in the Supernatural starring
Johnny Depp Christina Ricci Miranda
Richardson and directed by Tim Burton
critics say it isn't Tim Burton's best
work but Sleepy Hollow entertains with
its stunning visuals and creepy
atmosphere
foreign
foreign
the sleepy little town of Woodsboro just
woke up screaming there was a killer in
their midst who's seen a few too many
scary movies suddenly nobody is safe as
the psychopath socks victims taunts them
with trivia questions then rips them to
bloody shreds it could be anybody
starring Nev Campbell David Arquette
Courtney Cox and directed by Wes Craven
critics say horror icon Wes Craven's
subversive deconstruction of the genre
scream is a Sly witty and surprisingly
effective as a slasher film itself even
if it's a little too cheeky for some
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
yeah
I said what
whoa whoa whoa wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
audition
this disturbing Japanese Thriller
follows aoyama a widower who decides to
start dating again aided by a film
producer friend aoyama uses auditions
for fake production to function as a
dating service when aoyama becomes
intrigued by the withdrawn gorgeous
Asami they begin a relationship however
he begins to realize that Asami isn't as
reserved as she appears to be leading to
gradually increased tension and a
harrowing climax starring Rio ishibashi
ahishina Jun kunimura and directed by
Takashi Miki critics say an audacious
unsettling Japanese horror film from
director Takashi Miki audition
entertains as both a grisly shocker and
a psychological drama
oh oh
[Music]
okay
important
meaning
[Music]
and finally number one The Silence of
the Lambs
Jody Foster SARS is Clarice Starling a
top student at the FBI's Training
Academy Jack Crawford wants Clarice to
interview Dr Hannibal Lecter a brilliant
psychiatrist who is also a violent
psychopath serving life behind bars for
various acts of murder and cannibalism
Crawford believes that Lecter may have
insight into a case in that Clarice as
in attractive young woman may be just a
bait to draw him out starring Jody
Foster Anthony Hopkins Scott Glenn and
directed by Jonathan Demi critics say
Jonathan Demi smart taught Thriller the
Silence of the Lambs Teeters on the edge
between psychological study and all-out
horror and benefits greatly from Stellar
performances by Anthony Hopkins and Jody
Foster it rubs the lotion on its skin or
else it gets the hose again
well precious people get the hose okay
okay
okay
Mister if you let me go I won't I won't
press charges I promise I
see my mom is a real important woman I
guess you already know that I would
place this little ocean in the basket
[Music]
places to look through the basket
oh you
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love
until next time I am your host Naz Perez
and we will see you back here for more
top tens on the Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
foreign
[Music]